[MUSIC PLAYING]
SETH VARGO: Hello, everyone.
I am in the best possible
position, standing between you
and lunch.
So thank you all
so much for coming.
Today, I want to talk to you
about the various ways in which
we've invested in running
HashiCorp Vault on GCP
over the past year and
a half to two years.
This is a kind of high
level introductory talk.
I will be doing some
live demos, but we're not
going to really be getting
deep on any one topic.
So this is more of an
overview of some of the ways
that we've made investments
in the past year and a half
to two years.
Like Manu said, my name is Seth.
I work on the Developer
Relations team here at Google.
My Twitter handle is Seth Vargo.
If you have questions, comments,
complaints, or concerns,
you can tweet at me.
Please don't complain,
but otherwise fine.
If you have questions that
you don't feel comfortable
asking publicly, my direct
messages are also open.
So you can feel free to
send me a direct message.
Cool.
So with that, let's go
ahead and get started.
I want to provide a
quick overview of what
is Vault for those of you
that might not be aware,
and then we'll jump into some
of the GCP specific things
that we've been working on.
So in order to talk
about Vault, it's
important to talk
about what is a secret.
When we talk about
a secret, we're
specifically talking
about anything
that can be used to
authorize or authenticate.
So that might be a username and
password, an API token, a TLS
certificate.
But it also might be something
that's personally identifiable
or business intelligence
data, like a social security
number, a credit card, a
passport number, the API key
to access your internal
analytics dashboards that
give you a competitive
advantage in your market.
And given this problem
and given that secrets
are a common attack
vector because they often
have overly broad access or they
access critical systems data,
we often ask questions like
how do our applications get
secrets, how do
humans get secrets,
how are secrets updated,
how are they revoked,
who is using this secret right
now, why are they using it,
when are they done with it, and
what do we do in a compromise.
Because as much as we would
like to protect our secrets
and make sure that no one
ever has access to them,
at some point we have to accept
the reality that an attacker is
going to exploit a
vulnerability in our software,
or in our humans,
and they're going
to get access to our secrets.
So we need a plan
for rotation and we
need a plan for revocation.
What is the worst case scenario?
How quickly can we recover?
So what is our mean
time to patch a CVE?
What is our mean time to
recovery in case of a leak?
So Vault is an open-source
tool-- it's written in Go,
so it's free and
open-source-- that
is designed to answer these
questions and many more.
It tries to be a single
source of secrets
for your organization.
It provides programmatic access
so that machines and humans can
access the API, but
it also has a CLI
and a UI for human access.
So humans can interact
with the API or the UI,
and then machines, or other
applications and services,
can interact with
the API directly.
And it's important to note
that it's cloud friendly.
So Vault doesn't require that
you have some special hardware
or some special hardware device
attached to a physical machine.
This runs on native VMs and any
cloud provider, including GCP.
So it's a very cloud
friendly, works very well
in the cloud ecosystem.
You can even run
it in a container.
Vault encrypts all of
its data in transit
using TLS 1.2 or most recently
1.3 for client authentication.
The data is encrypted at
rest with 256-bit AES-GCM
encryption, and it offers a
hierarchical key value store
for storing data.
So it's a path based
approach to storing data.
And the data inside a
secret is a key value pair.
One of the things that's
really interesting about Vault
is that it offers
dynamic secrets.
So in a traditional
world, let's say
I need a database username and
password to connect to my MySQL
instance.
Well, an operator
has to provision
that credential by running
create user and the SQL
command, and then they take that
username and password and they
put in a text file to give
it to the application.
With Vault, Vault can
actually run that SQL for you
and provision that
user automatically.
So a human never
sees the credential,
only the end application
sees the credential.
And this helps you
maintain provenance--
a one to one mapping
between a credential
and the application or
service that's consuming it.
This gives us a really
tight audit trail,
and it allows us to time
bound our credentials.
So instead of having a human
create a credential that
lives forever, we
can have a machine
create a credential
that's valid for 24 hours,
or a week or a month.
And by auto-expiring
these credentials,
we reduce our surface
area for an attack.
We reduce the number
of credentials
and we reduce secret sprawl.
And more importantly, we can
revoke any of those credentials
at any time in the
event of a data breach.
Humans or machines authenticate
to Vault by providing
some type of credential.
Vault then goes to these
third party databases--
things like Redis,
MySQL, Postgres,
or as we'll see in a
bit, Google Cloud--
and dynamically generate
credentials on the fly
and return them
to the requester.
Each time someone
requests a credential,
they get a brand new
unique credential.
And Vault is pluggable.
So I already mentioned
MySQL, Postgres, et cetera.
Basically any SQL database,
including Oracle and MongoDB
and SQL Server, are
supported for the database
side of things.
There's also cloud
provider support.
So at Google, we have
full time engineers
who are contributing
support to Vault. There's
also plugins for other clouds
for your multi-cloud strategy,
like AWS, or Azure,
or Oracle, or VMware.
But then there are other
systems that we don't think
of when we talk about secrets.
But things like RabbitMQ--
how do you get that
API key out there?
Things like SSH access--
how do you maintain
the ability for people
to access into systems?
Things like managing TLS
certificates-- running
your own PKI infrastructure.
Vault can actually act as
a certificate authority
or an intermediate
certificate authority
providing TLS or mutual
TLS authentications
between your microservices.
It obviously integrates
really well with other tools
in the HashiCorp ecosystem,
and most recently you
can also use it to provision
Active Directory users,
as well as OpenID
Connect providers.
So what are some ways that
you can use Vault with GCP?
So we made a few key
investments in a few areas that
allow you, as Google Cloud
customers and Google Cloud
consumers, to gain the
benefits of running Vault
as an open-source product on
GCP while leveraging other GCP
tools and technologies.
And the first one I want to
talk about is storage backends.
So Vault itself is actually
a stateless service.
It instead has pluggable
storage backends.
Storage backend is just
where Vault puts its data.
The easiest one to think
about is the file system.
Vault is just going to write
its data to the file system.
It also has an
in-memory implementation
where it will store all
of its data in memory.
And when you stop the process,
all of that data is lost.
It's great for
local development.
But in production, how could
you run Vault against a storage
backend that's highly
available, provides
high availability,
high durability,
but also is low maintenance?
Right, ideally you don't
want to carry a pager just
for your storage backend.
So we've made some key
investments on GCP.
The first storage
backend, which is probably
the most common
among our customers,
is the Google Cloud Storage,
or the GCS storage backend.
This is a GCP native
storage backend.
You create a Google
Cloud Storage bucket.
You grant Vault, or
a service account
running Vault, permission
to read and write data
from that storage bucket.
That will give you three and
a half nines of availability.
You don't have to
carry the pager,
we carry that pager for you.
And it allows you to run Vault
in high availability mode.
So this allows you to run
multiple Vault instances
in high availability
mode for you.
Another storage backend we offer
for our enterprise customers
or for customers who need a
little bit more availability is
our Google Cloud
Spanner storage backend.
Google Cloud Spanner
is GCP native.
It gives you five
nines of availability
in the highest configuration.
Also supports Vaults
high availability mode.
It also supports
Vault Enterprise.
If you're running HashiCorps
proprietary enterprise
offering, it's supported
on Spanner but not GCS
because of the way that
Vault Enterprise requires
a transactional interface.
Again, both of these
storage backends
support high availability.
Both of these
storage backends are
available with zero
maintenance to you,
Google carries the pager.
And the slides and I'm
showing you here are exactly
how easy it is to add this
configuration to your Vault
server config.
It's just three or four lines
of configuration and the IAM
authentication and now you're
using a Google Cloud supported
storage backend.
Both of these
storage backends were
contributed by Google
engineers to Vault core.
They're available in the Vault
open-source distribution.
You don't need to
install a plugin
or run any sidecar applications.
You can download
Vault today, or really
any of the recent versions of
Vault. These configurations
[? stanzas ?] will
work out of the box.
They also support GCP
native default application
credentials.
That means if you're running
Vault on a Google Compute
Engine instance, a Google
Container Engine instance,
or Google Kubernetes
engine instance, Cloud Run,
Cloud Functions-- anything that
supports instance metadata--
you can attach a service account
to that VM or that underlying
runtime, and it
will automatically
authenticate so you don't
have to worry about passing
around a service account.
So those are the
storage backends.
Now let's talk about
secrets engines.
So in Vault, secrets engines
are pluggable systems
that allow us to extend
Vault's functionality.
And there are two
secrets engines
that I want to talk
to you about today
that can really help accelerate
the way that you do security
with GCP.
The first is our
IAM secrets engine.
So this is our Google Cloud
Identity and Access Management
Vault secrets engine plugin.
It's a mouthful.
What this allows us
to do is to configure
Vault to generate OAuth2
access tokens for provisioning
access to Google Cloud.
So what I do is
I configure Vault
with a service account
and some permissions,
and then I say,
hey Vault I would
like you to generate
service accounts or OAuth2
tokens for me whenever someone
interacts with this path.
What Vault is going
to do is it's then
going to make the various
API calls to Google Cloud.
And it will generate
an OAuth2 access token
which expires in a
certain amount of time,
in this example 60 minutes.
So this is an
OAuth2 access token
that you can use to sign
and authenticate requests
to Google Cloud.
And they're
automatically cleaned up
after that 60 minutes expires.
Unless you write
this yourself, Vault
is actually the only
way to date to have time
based GCP-IAM credentials
that automatically expire.
This allows you to provide
automated short-term access
to your various Google resources
with very little overhead.
So you imagine you have
some batch process that
needs to get some information
from a cloud storage bucket,
decrypt it with Cloud
KMS, run some data,
and store the results somewhere.
You can leverage a
secrets engine like this
to generate those credentials
for you that automatically
expire whenever the job expires.
So you don't have to worry
about leaking those credentials
or having a long running service
account with permissions.
The next secrets
engine, which is
one of our newest
secrets engine,
is the Google Cloud
KMS secrets engine.
This secrets engine
is an abstraction
on top of Google Cloud KMS,
our Key Management Service.
The Google Cloud
KMS secrets engine
allows you to create, manage,
delete, update, encrypt,
decrypt, sign, verify all kinds
of data through Vault's API.
Now, you could do this by
using the Google Cloud KMS
API directly.
All of the functionality
that we expose in the plugin
is also available via the
API or the UI directly.
But we have a lot of
customers who are already
heavily invested
in Vault, and they
wanted to use the same
interface, the same policies,
the same authentication
that they're already
using for their multi-cloud
strategy or their hybrid cloud
strategy.
But they want to leverage
Google Cloud KMS,
and this plugin is a way
that you can do that.
The coolest part
about this plugin,
though, is that it
actually allows you
to encrypt and decrypt data
backed by a Hardware Security
Module, an HSM.
And this is exposed via
the Google Cloud KMS APIs.
So just by reading and writing
from a JSON REST endpoint,
you can actually have your
data be encrypted and decrypted
by a physical hardware
security module, up to FIPS 142
level three, if you have
those regulatory requirements.
So again this is GCP native,
integrates with Cloud HSM,
you can manage your
keys using Vault,
you can use your existing
policies and configurations
in Vault, and you could
encrypt, sign, verify,
decrypt data using
the Vault API.
So instead of just showing
you this on a slide,
I figured I'd show you
what this looks like.
So with that, we'll jump
over to the live demo.
So I have a Vault server
here already set up.
It's running on Google
Kubernetes Engine.
And I'm just going
to go ahead and run
Vault read GCP token dev token.
And what this is going to do--
in real time, this is very real.
You would theoretically
be able to use that token
for the next 60 minutes
if I don't revoke it
by the end of this talk.
This will give you
access to this project.
You can't actually do
anything in the project,
but this is real.
Every time I run this command
I'll actually get a new Google
Cloud access token.
This is an access token that
I can authenticate to the API
with.
It is an OAuth2 bearer token.
And I can give this to any
of the Google Cloud client
libraries, or any service
account or any type
of officially
supported tool, and it
will authenticate
as this user and be
able to access the APIs and the
permissions as dictated by IAM.
So that's actually just how easy
it is to generate these tokens.
And again, they automatically
expire after 60 minutes.
I've already configured
the GCP KMS plugin,
and I'm going to
save some typing
by copying it to my clipboard.
So here I'm using the Vault
API to encrypt and decrypt data
using the Google Cloud
KMS managed keys.
So all I do is I ask Vault
to encrypt some data.
In this case, I gave
it the plaintext "hi",
and Vault gives me back
some encrypted cipher text.
From here I can also
create new keys,
rotate keys, upgrade
keys, and even delete
keys all using Vault's API.
Under the hood, that's backed
by Google Cloud KMS and Google
Cloud HSM, but it's abstracted
for you at the API layer.
So all of these secrets
engines are developed by Google
as plugins.
So they are third party
plugins, but they're
bundled automatically
in all Vault open-source
distributions.
So even though they're
developed third party plugins
they're included in
Vault's distribution, which
means you don't have to download
or install them on your own.
If you download any
recent version of Vault,
they'll be available for you.
And as I said before, just
like the storage backends,
these secrets engines support
the Google Cloud Application
Default Credentials,
which means you
don't have to worry about
passing around service accounts
if you're on a Google managed
VM or something with instance
metadata.
So the last thing I want to
talk about is auth methods.
So we've talked about how
you can run Vault on GCP.
We've talked about how you can
provision accounts and interact
with KMS.
But if I'm a Google
Cloud user-- maybe
I'm a G Suite user,
a Google Cloud user,
I have these service
accounts-- how
do my humans or my
applications authenticate
to Vault using GCP?
In other words, can I leverage
GCP as my source of trust
for my underlying
authentication?
And we can.
We actually have the
Google Cloud auth method.
In Vault, an auth
method is the way
in which we convert human or
machine supplied information
into an authentication
credential.
And this is what it looks like.
We can log into Vault
using the GCP method
with a particular
role, a service
account, and the underlying
service account credentials.
Vault will authenticate this
against the Google Cloud IAM
APIs, and it will give
me back a Vault session--
a Vault token, if you will.
And this allows me
to then interact
with Vault given any
pre-configured policies
that my security team might
have created in advance.
So this is GCP native.
It allows you to authenticate
with IAM service accounts
or GCE instance metadata.
So you can actually
authenticate to Vault
just because you are
an instance in GCE
or anything that has
instance metadata.
And it has support for
Vault group aliases
and policy management, which
is really important if you're
running Vault Enterprise and
you want to use namespaces.
So very quickly, let me show
you what this looks like.
It's thinking.
So it does take a
little bit longer
because we have to make
a few different API
calls to authenticate
the request,
but what I did here is I gave
Vault my credential, as well
as the service account that
I'm authenticating with
and the role in which
I'm authenticating.
And Vault gives me back a token.
That token has some policies.
So I basically get a
session with policies
attached that were
configured and managed
by my security team.
So I just authenticate to Vault
using my existing Google Cloud
credentials.
So this is a great way to trust
Vault as the source of truth
for secrets, but then
leverage the identity bits
to Google Cloud.
On Google Kubernetes Engine,
or any Kubernetes cluster,
we also have the
Kubernetes auth method.
Now this is not something
that Google engineers
have specifically developed.
We've partnered with
a number of folks,
including folks at HashiCorp,
to write the Kubernetes auth
method.
But this is a way to
authenticate pods and services
in Kubernetes
engine using Vault.
This is GCP agnostic.
It allows you to
restrict access via RBAC
permissions and various
Kubernetes service accounts.
You can restrict access
by Kubernetes namespaces.
And it works great on GKE,
because GKE is just Kubernetes.
But this also works if you
have GKE on-prem with Anthos.
If you have your own AKS
cluster or EKS cluster,
because this is
Kubernetes native,
it'll work on all
of those as well.
So these auth methods
are developed as plugins.
Some of them are
maintained and contributed
by Google engineers.
They are also bundled in
the open-source distribution
of Vault. So again,
you don't have
to worry about installing
them yourselves.
They just have a separate
development velocity
than Vault core.
And they help solve that
first secret problem.
How do I authenticate
to Vault without hard
coding our
credentials somewhere,
how does all of this work?
So these auth methods
help you do that
by delegating trust to
either the Cloud platform
or the Kubernetes API server.
So I have a few links.
If you're going to take
a picture of a slide,
this is the one to
take a picture of.
There are a few things here
that are really important.
The Cloud Spanner and the
Cloud Storage backends
are heavily documented, as well
as all of our secret engines,
including all of
our auth methods.
So everything I've talked about
here today is on this slide,
except the last one.
And I have one minute
left, so I'm actually
going to show it to you.
So the Vault fluent
deconfigurations
allow us to abstract Vault
audit logs and system logs
into Stackdriver in a
really friendly way.
And I'm glad I have an extra
minute, because this is just
really cool to me.
So I'm going to go
ahead and jump over here
into the Google Cloud
console and make
this a little bit bigger.
I've configured this in advance.
So again, I'm running Vault
on GCE VMs in this case.
And you'll notice if I click
on this little drop down,
I have two tags--
the Vault project io audit
and Vault project io server.
The audit logs are
actually Vault audit logs.
Vault audits every request
and response in the system.
And the server logs are
just the operational logs,
what you would expect to
see from any microservice
or any long running service.
I'm going to go ahead and
filter by the audit logs here.
Here are audit logs where--
and this is directly using that
fluent deconfiguration--
I have my IP address, the
alias ID of the credential,
the API method I used, and
the path that I accessed.
And right inside
Stackdriver, I can actually
drill down into the direct
request and response headers
in the JSON payload.
This is structured.
This is available, and I
can actually filter directly
on some of this data.
So if I just want to click
show matching entries,
I can see all of the requests
that that particular token made
right from inside Stackdriver.
And this is not
Vault specific, but
those fluent
deconfigurations allow
the audit logs to
be parsed in a way
that Stackdriver exposes
this functionality to you.
That's all I have
for you here today.
Thank you all so very much.
I'll be available for questions
outside of the dev zone.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]